good afternoon I am the Dean of the
Dietrich College of Humanities and
Social Sciences one of seven great
colleges at Carnegie Mellon before we
start I just want to thank president
Suresh and my wife it's my birthday
today and over breakfast my wife asked
me what I want my birthday I don't know
I said give me a few minutes to think
about it and about an hour later I got
an email from president Suresh
announcing this wonderful gift so I
yelled down to her how about a new
building for Dietrich College great idea
she said I'll tell subra it's your
birthday and see what I can do so long
story short I'm delighted to accept this
new building for Dietrich holiday as my
birthday present sorry to all you other
Dean's before I introduce our panelists
I want to mention that several people
will be distributing note cards for
anyone who would like to submit a
question to the panel you identify
yourself now yes there's people gonna be
walking around if you want to actually
pose a question give them a signal
they'll give you a card you can write it
down they'll collect it in the aisle and
then Steve claim will be selecting the
questions to pose to the panel as you
can see I have the easy job
so in some form or other government's
industries and academics have been
partnering for several thousand years in
the last century however and
particularly in the last 20 to 30 years
the amount of money devoted to R&D by
governments industries and universities
has exploded although their interests
often overlap their core missions do
differ the core mission of government is
to establish justice provide for the
common defense and perhaps to ensure
that society has the general
infrastructure upon which it can thrive
the core mission of Industry is to
achieve profit for its shareholders and
the core mission of universities is to
produce new knowledge and to educate not
only in science and technology but in
the social sciences humanities
and the arts despite these differences
all three agree that the benefits from
collaboration are potentially enormous
and then does pursue it clearly there
are risks the Academy cannot be driven
entirely by the needs of companies or
governments it must be free to pursue
its own agenda an industry that invests
heavily in academia might gain no
advantage the forms of collaboration
between industry and the Academy have
changed basic research units like Bell
Labs and Xerox PARC are rarely housed
and funded with an industry nowadays and
they will continue to change in the 21st
century knowledge-based global economy
world-class research universities like
Carnegie Mellon and world-class
companies like TCS will explore new ways
to partner hopefully they can find ways
to do so that will not only improve the
industries and universities involved but
also the regions around them both
economically and socially how then
should the academy and industry align
themselves in an environment that is
truly global and increasingly
competitive so to reflect on these
issues and related ones we have convened
a distinguished panel which I would like
to introduce to you now so panelists
please join me up here in the front of
the room have your seats J Whittaker is
a professor of engineering and public
policy materials science and engineering
at Carnegie Mellon dr. Whittaker works
on synthesizing characterizing and
implementing promising materials and
device architectures for energy storage
and generation technologies such as
lithium-ion batteries fuel cells and
photovoltaics he also explores the
policy implications involved with
selecting and implementing renewable
energy technologies dr. Whittaker holds
five patents granted or pending and he's
authored or co-authored more than 20
peer-reviewed journal articles and has
received numerous awards yen ala calvess
avec kovachev ik sorry is the david
edward Schrom professor and head of
electrical and computer engineering a
professor of biomedical engineering
and dr. Culver Savage recent work has
focused on providing signal
representation tools to be used
primarily in communication and
biomedical systems she was a fellow of
the I Triple E and E us IP Co which I
takes to European signal processing
something an entrepreneur in her own
right and co-author of multiple books
Chandra you've been introduced to and
since we have heard from Chandra already
I'd like to begin by providing je and
Yelena an opportunity to briefly talk
about their own experiences with
industry academic partnerships and the
comments on how they have impacted your
careers either positively or negatively
Jay thank you I anyone hear me okay okay
um I came to Carnegie Mellon about eight
years ago I was previously a rocket
scientist not really but I worked at the
Jet Propulsion lab and I did work on
some really exciting projects there but
they weren't in my experience what I
wanted to do with my life I want to do
something that maybe had more immediate
impact on direct societal needs so this
position at CMU that I took is very
unusual half materials science and
engineering which is a more common
well-established field and this other
department called engineering and public
policy which is a kind of an unusual
thing it's a policy Department and an
engineering school where we study the
technical and economic aspects of policy
decisions and we try to inform good
decision-making visa vie good technical
analysis this is so exciting to me what
a jump from sort of working for NASA to
doing that in my early time here I
investigated or considered well what
what can I do well and what a society
needs in very large format very
inexpensive energy storage was something
that became really apparent as a need as
a whole out there and in the technical
space that I could contribute to so I
started in did some experiments found
since then things and in 2008 had a
couple results that were compelling
enough to garner some funding I had a
choice to make at that point do I go
with
a more traditional academic path of
trying to find money from a government
sponsor somewhere or at the time there
was a huge amount of interest in the
venture funding community on this kind
of thing I chose that path I brought in
a fair amount of money we set up an
incubation project within the confines
of CMU CMU allowed this to happen for
which I'm very grateful when we
incubated this new idea at the
University when it ripened to the extent
that it was ready which took about a
year year and a half we spun it out and
we spun it out here in Lawrenceville in
Pennsylvania the company now is known as
aqueon energy and it now has 160
employees and we are producing and
shipping product around the world at the
factory in Westmoreland County the old
Sony Factory so it's gone from this
basic idea that started here at CMU to a
multinational organization that is
producing and shipping product in about
six and a half seven years which is fast
if you follow innovation Theory
especially materials intensive invention
and innovation you realize that that's a
quick path and we did we cut a lot of
corners we made a lot of mistakes but we
also did some really good things and the
key thing was recruiting best possible
teammates to move to Pittsburgh and to
make this happen and to continue to
garner the interplay between the stuff
that was coming out of the university
the stuff that was happening and they
are in D lab and the stuff that was
happening at the factory there's this
really intricate dance that you do
between the results that happen these
different locations to find the shortest
path between invention and product and I
feel like it's something I've lived you
know very intimately the past five or
six years and it's been it's been a
great it's been a great experience we've
raised now about a hundred and
thirty-five hundred forty million
dollars and we are now bringing in real
revenue which is super exciting so and I
want to thank the state of Pennsylvania
as well for giving us support and and
also a couple of key government agencies
Department of Energy early on also gave
us great support to make this happen so
it's been a lovely amazing experience
that I'm happy to talk about more
jelena so I came here from Bell Labs in
2003 and I thought I would change the
scale of this discussion you know go
more from an individual researcher
faculty member point of view so what I
do is really build mathematical models
to mine information from data signals it
can be images it can be audio signals it
can be stock market signals what have
you and the last ten or so years have
been working mostly in mining data from
biological and medical images so one
interesting project that I have now
that's the part of industry
collaboration is building such models
and software to diagnose middle ear
infection and the reason for doing this
is you could go to a pediatrician but
they're actually in victoriously bad at
doing that or not bad but you know
they're their conditions that look
similar when you look into the ear and
if you could actually do this
automatically with you know a model and
a piece of software that would be of
great value as a diagnostic aid and
we're doing this actually in
collaboration with Children's Hospital
at the University of Pittsburgh
Enrico innovations with whose CEO is
also from India and he's in ECE om and
we are building or they're rather
building a prototype otoscope which is
you know what the pediatrician puts into
the kid's ear to take a picture and then
the software or models would
automatically sort of diagnose the
condition now from my point of view I
went into this field because of math but
I became an engineer so it's extremely
satisfying to feel that my work actually
could potentially have larger impact
outside of me and you know my own
intellectual satisfaction for doing what
I'm doing now from another point of view
as a department head of a really large
department actually largest on campus
and number of faculty it's really
important to see the benefits from both
sides we as faculty have the luxury and
the benefit of potentially looking
further ahead being you know able to
dream a little bit while the industry
doesn't have that luxury but on the
other hand you have the sense in the
pulse of the market and together these
two discs
nation can really create powerful impact
the companies have access to top talent
and we in turn get access to companies
in place our students which of course
you know all of them eventually want to
find jobs after they get this great CMU
degrees and finally there is the
education and learning part of it you
know by placing our students into
internships they get to see what the
real world looks like and have this more
gradual sort of ascent from being only
their work being only about being
educated to their work being only about
being at work so there is this really
symbiosis between the two and mutual
benefits that I think as this is yet
another example of how we could create
something really powerful by partnering
with companies that have the virtue as
as the governor said to see the virtue
in assets at Carnegie Mellon so thank
you so maybe you could chandra comment a
little bit on what you see as the role
governments can play both local
statewide federal and global on making
these partnerships not only attractive
but also structured so they benefit
industry academia but also a society at
large that's a very long question take
any part of it I think the the most
important thing is the ability to
collaborate I made a remark in my in my
speech with the technological changes
that are happening not only
technological economic societal I think
if you take all the dimensions probably
we are going through one of one of the
unique times where we are going to
change in multiple dimensions the
problems are different in different
parts of the globe and the underlying
principle is the technology is going to
be the
main driver in solving problems of
different nature for industry for
society for economic growth etc and
partnerships like this will become lot
more important than average for in my
mind and government's have to promote
these partnerships and how they will do
it is by the very presence here of the
governor is a very important statement
sometimes it is symbolic sometimes it is
policy sometimes it is funding so subra
said that he's gonna work with the
government to get the roads sorted out
here so I think it's the if the
importance of the collaboration because
we as as was pointed out as I mean as
industry we we have that experience we
feel the problems much more closely but
at the same time we get caught up in
meeting the court in numbers alright
we've delivered numbers so we we can't
say that we will take the next five
years or four years they will take well
we have to do that we're going to keep
an eye on on the card that we're driving
on the highway so so that's the
challenge so many many people comment on
or ask questions about how intellectual
property needs to be managed so these
partnerships can be successful so only
pose that question to the panel you've
all had experience directly I think the
situation differs from country to
country even state to state but could
you relate any of your experiences in
terms of what worked and what didn't
work with respect to intellectual
property and how that works
sure okay so so it's interesting because
I had two different experiences in Bell
apps this was sort of a well-oiled
machine so there was an IT department
and I would sort of systematically go
you know look at what people were
producing and just sort of forces to do
patents right and you know then I think
what what will happen the big companies
at the time you know IBM Research and
Bell Labs would trade you know patents
in bulk here it was different it was
much more I was much more involved in
the process of you know the pattern to
it for example a recall and I could see
that you know you can really get stuck
you know on some I'm not saying it's a
small but you you get stuck on one issue
and it takes a long time to move from
there so finding ways of facilitating or
creating sort of boiler plates you know
agreements which I think you know CMU is
doing now are trying to do very much
like master agreements to simplify this
and to take this part away from the
collaboration and to let it go forward
because this would really stop us that's
that's I think one of the key issues you
know in the university environment Jay
yeah I think the obligation that
universities have the United States to
not allow IP to be assigned to funders
until the whatever it is that has been
funded is able to reach a fair market
assessment this is all buried in the IRS
tax code because we can't do that
there's a real limitation I know I
personally involved with several
negotiations with outside potential
industry partners who would love to be
part of what's going on at CMU but their
lawyers simply have a thing well if
we're funding a new we will own your
intellectual property and as a you know
grant barring federal grant bearing
institution we are unable to do that and
this is a reality of the way that the
university of the industry react
interacting in this country you know a
side story is that a close colleague of
mine who happens to be a Canadian
professor has a very different situation
he's enjoyed multiple millions of
dollars per year from 3m for over a
decade to do amazing research he's built
up an extraordinary lab and he is
probably one of if not the most famous
researcher in this field part or greatly
because of the fact that the same
boundaries don't exist
as they do in the United States I'm not
saying that it's bad or that it's good
either way but it's a fact and it's
something that because we have lawyers
on both sides of the organizations and
we have to figure out very every time
there's some difference sticking point
you know something happens we have to
find a way around it and oftentimes it's
not a good even practical solution for
you to decide
sometimes nothing ever happens so that's
difficult and it's it's I don't have in
mind a solution but I can certainly
describe the problem well maybe maybe
Chandra you could follow up on that and
describe how things differ across
different international boundaries and
situations because I'm sure you've dealt
with I think it's uh it's the most
complicated subject in terms of who
wants to IP
many times people say we cleared joint
IP I never understand that because you
know either you have that you don't have
it so people come up with ways to
resolve them sometimes they give royalty
free perpetual license to one party the
other party takes it for monetizing
sometimes it's a non-exclusive on both
sides so there are various ways by which
people resolve but the fact of the
matter is that there is no uniform brain
which it can be easily solved and it is
easily solved in any part of them any
part of the world and I was talking
during lunch and understand that you
have developed some different models one
of the things I said to subra is that
you've got to figure out a way by which
we as to be progress or relationship to
joint research and so on and so forth we
don't get stuck on these things right so
we've got to have some templates and
whenever we have a tough issue we've
gotta have a mechanism to find a way out
because it shouldn't stop the speed
agility is key in today's world agility
is key and most of the agility is not
about running fast it's about not
creating roadblocks internally
most most organizations have those
roadblocks because either because of
bureaucracy or because we can't agree on
some something so they gotta be spending
time on the market at least as
businesses I feel that 90% should be
spent on the market or not on not on
solving these issues but it's complex
are are there are there large
differences in the IP setting in Asia
and Europe in America or is it rough I
think I would say that here it's a lot
more mature and I think u.s. is not more
mature than other markets are still
still developing your chaotic ok let's
open the floor some audience questions
Steve would you sure there we go we have
a question here about the global nature
of the partnership in this globalizing
world we've talked about how the
boundaries are blurring how do you
choose where to make your investment
that question in hand is is related to
TCS but I think you could ask it the
other way how does how does a university
choose which partners to spend time with
so my point is I think it's their very
global not thinking as well so to me
what attracted TCS towards Carnegie
Mellon is the areas in which we are
focusing and the areas which CMU has a
dominant position whether those areas
robotics machine learning analytics and
these kind of areas there is a there is
a cutting edge work that's going on and
the computer science education in
Carnegie Mellon and the research in
computer science in Carnegie Mellon is
renowned I mean you can go by service
you can go by what people say but at the
end of the day when you when you know
and when you see that that strength is
then the university that's going to rub
on TCS and you know there's Mellon but
in terms of what we want to do and what
diversity is focused on so so it
personally itself with an opportunity
and then we said is the right thing to
do so it's not really and my team and I
had to go through the board approval
process like you have to do so breath so
oh so let me let me turn the question
around and ask you Elena as you're a
head of the department if you were
considering what strategic moves you
would make for the department to attract
corporate partnerships or to involve
yours your department in how would you
how would you look at that well you well
that's an interesting one because every
time we look at this it's it's a really
multifaceted problems that also involves
you know involving our alums sitting in
these corporations and you need to have
a champion within the company this will
never happened without you right so you
need to create this you you need to
create these relationships and you need
to nurture them and find what
strategically make sense for us Carnegie
Mellon has never been a place that does
everything we cannot possibly do
everything so we need to focus ourselves
on a few key areas where we feel we have
the strengths and we can make a
difference and then strategically find
those companies where we can make such
you know such such connections and so
this is exactly what we do in terms of
when we think about our strategic
planning what are the trust key trust
areas let's say for the department and
then how do we go out and look at the
top companies in these areas to engage
them to work with us because this is
really it's key for the companies as I
said it's it's a it's a wonderful
opportunity to get access to top talent
and you know top of the leadership
talent and in a general Thailand through
PhD students and so on and for us to for
our faculty to have funding to do the
research that they need to do given the
you know how the funding is going in
terms of federal funding that you know
it's been flat and we don't know what's
gonna happen in the future
we need to be more agile in creating
creating such partnerships even more
than before
Dean Janis you mentioned earlier the
different purposes of universities and
corporations and we have a couple of
questions
here that go to the questions of culture
universities are very different places
from corporations with with different
core motivations perhaps overlapping
sets of interest but different cultures
what are the risks and obstacles that
that presents how do you overcome them
and what are their benefits that come
out of bringing to such distinct kinds
of cultures together Jay you want to
take that at first yeah I think you know
in both worlds yeah having a foot in
both those worlds and it's funny when
it's when a technology or a company
emerges from just an idea
there's almost no separation culturally
and what's been fascinating is to watch
how as you mature at the technology and
the entity the venture you need a
different sort of people and a different
sort of culture to make it really
ultimately effective and it's it's
complicated to grow in that way so I
really can appreciate that there's these
different buckets I think both sides
have and the best of worlds can really
appreciate each other and I think one of
the things in general is that it's
somewhat lopsided I feel like the
industrial world or the commercial world
has a deep appreciation for the academic
and I think the academic side of thing
often times doesn't have good visibility
into what's happening in the commercial
world industrial processes industrial
level or true business level
decision-making is often either not not
of interest to academics or it's just
something they're not presented with
with enough resolution to be interesting
to them and that that dichotomy is kind
of interesting in itself and so I find
myself now realizing how interesting
some industrial it's just engineering
kinds of projects are they're actually
deeply fundamental and they could be
highly academic but they're just not
seen that way in the academic community
and so you know one thing that could be
done I think is to pull a bit more of
what is interesting about it about the
the manufacturing industrial world you
can distill out some really amazing more
fundamental things that I think could
project an academia
more effectively especially the
bottlenecks maybe don't need you yeah
those keep all next in they're not it's
not just engineering it's not just this
go solve the problem there's some real
interesting basic things that could be
done that often I I I see a lot of the
work that's being done and you know if
that person would just look at this
problem this could be fascinating and
boy could we solve this faster Chandra
you had some I think it's the beauty of
of this whole thing is about having
those two cultures on the one side on
the other side when or you are trying to
solve a problem and people who come
together they they kind of have a common
objective I mean if you're talking about
researching you know things are in or in
solving a specific problem and
driverless car or whatever it is the the
people from in this case TCS and the
researchers from CMU or driven by the
common objective then you know then the
passion takes over everything else right
so it's finding the common problem yeah
it's funny the common interest
it's the problems at the end of the day
which which drive people try people yeah
I don't think that in the end there are
real obstacle to the cultures themselves
pose obstacles because if you get
together and you have something you want
to do together you know it's actually
these these different cultures just
bring a diverse points of view so it's I
I don't know that we have you know that
I've ever heard of people not enjoying
this or not and you know this was any
sort of an obstacle if anything it's
actually exciting I have a great
question here that same toward the TCS
are framed about the TCS CMU
collaboration but I think could be
opened up more broadly to all industry
academic partnerships how do you engage
students what can they bring to it how
do they benefit from it I think one of
the objectives for us in this whole
partnership is team
students I think what we envisage is to
is to create a number of projects which
are going to be giant projects we
imagine that there will be teachers
researchers will be collocated here with
same you faculty CMU students solving a
particular problem and you've got some
idea about the areas we want to focus on
and the reverse will also happen we hope
that some some one CMU faculty will
visit and be with us and you know work
with us in our labs and in india at time
to time maybe CMU students will be part
of one of these projects and may do
interns in pcs in some exciting projects
and the other thing we are talking about
is how to engage students in some of the
engineering colleges with whom we work
in India how do we bring those students
together on the CMU students together
maybe through an online platform maybe
through you've got some ideas we've got
some prototypes those details are we we
work through but the most exciting thing
in this whole partnership is not only
the research element but also the idea
generation by getting all these students
together because you know I was in a
speech we're all looking for the best
talent probably you're looking for the
best faculty best off and try to recruit
the right students and we are trying to
recruit the best students coming over
here so I just wanted to add that we
just had this summer the first instance
of this internship program with the PS
School of Engineering in Bangalore and
this was actually through again the
connections are it's all about
connections it was my my ex PhD student
who wanted to create some sort of a
formalized internship program with CMU
and they sent they actually we cared
their best students with our faculty and
faculty we're really excited to get this
underground the interns and they were
fantastic so you know they're gonna go
back they worked with our faculty in our
graduate students they're going
go back and it's kind of like you know
it's a it's a multiplier right so the
good things from CMU go that way and you
know we we will be able to go back and
you know perhaps a change in our faculty
will go there and give talks and so on
if we have now an industrial or
corporate partner we can you know add
more of these you know educational
institutions and no more than one place
plus industry to help us perhaps
facilitate that yeah and just to
reinforce that we truly are in a
national university a huge fraction of
our graduate student population and
indeed undergrad as well international
and a lot of these folks come here with
the intention of going back and so the
opportunity exists already for us to
have this impact visa just with a good
education in providing them you know
what Carnegie Mellon has to offer here
in Pittsburgh but also other campuses
around the world and this is just gonna
add to it and and maybe providing
destinations in India that are more
explicit this is a you know a Tata CMU
collaborative site in India our Indian
and other students may have a you know a
more specific point of focus to go back
to time for one more question just about
one so to loop back to the to an
original topic what are what are the
conditions under which well let me let
me preface it with a little of my own
personal knowledge there universities
all across this country and cities all
across this country that are anxious to
try to promote these kind of
partnerships there are fewer places
where that actually flourishes what are
the conditions under which these kind of
partnerships can flourish or what is I
sometimes hear people say around this
campus is the secret sauce
please
nice job conditions give them even the
minimum amount of resources magic
happens so by providing scholarship to
students you make it easier innovation
and often say it's a contact sport you
increase the amount of contact
innovation the other thing which many of
you already referred to is the diversity
when people from different backgrounds
are different diversity in the broader
sense people coming from very different
backgrounds very very different
disciplines in which they are trained
very different cultural backgrounds
racial backgrounds geographical
backgrounds national backgrounds look at
the same problem they look at it from
very different vantage points so they do
much better with respect to innovation
than any homogeneous group addressing
the same problem it doesn't matter what
the homogeneous group is so innovation
by itself is significantly enriched and
enhanced when you put future
disciplinary perspectives and
intercultural inter international
perspectives so Carnegie Mellon has the
secret sauce and many great American
research you know is
applesauce and Carnegie Mellon is one of
the great American research universities
and I think we have historically have to
compete we've done a lot with little
resources but part of my objective part
of my job through these engagements is
to provide the faculty and students
let me close this and invite you to come
to the reception that will follow this
immediately but let me think take this
opportunity then all our panelists thank
our moderator Richard China's je Elena
Chandra for coming all the way he flew
in from Mumbai just over the weekend
Freddie was going to come in arrived
this morning I tried to talk him out of
it but is amazing I also want to thank
all our colleagues from TCS for
traveling very large distances to be
with us today I wanna thank governor
wolf once again from your busy schedule
we look forward to the